what interests me is that if I sow a
seed of doubt no one so far as they were
upset ya know with certainty this is one
of these now I haven't told anyone
they're wrong in fact I never right but
you have to know you're right not
because I told you you have to know
you're right because mathematically you
can convince yourself just like with
things like it must be elsewhere and why
it's not just a square plus B square so
I want you to have a look the way I'm
going to convince myself is by thinking
about this numerically algebra is hard
however is one level abstraction above
numbers okay so if he died covered it
unders okay he's an example see that
three in the one in the fall I have
written everything in this somewhat
cumbersome but more instructive NCR
notation okay which terms have I
highlighted in orange over here which
one
this one is 3 C 2 do you agree can you
see the Carlo yeah so it's not one then
I've got one next to it which is 3 3 C 3
and then when you add those guys
together you get the one that's in
between 43 you're you're ok with that
ok so I can write this in at least two
ways maybe a couple more let's think
about this actually definitely I've run
out of space so I'm going to go to here
if I call this guy here because remember
I did it over here but I could do this
anywhere I can make this triangle shape
anywhere on pastor's phone if I call the
3 c2 if I call that and see right then
what is the term next to him it's it's
going to B and C plus 1 I'm still in the
same row but I've gone one term along do
you agree ok so if you add them is what
you get is something on the next row so
I don't write NC whatever I write M plus
1 I've gone one one row down does that
make sense so I'm gonna have n plus 1
which term and wake up to now on this
example I want the third one which is R
plus one isn't it do you see that do you
like that so here is one of the ways
that we can write this it's not the only
way though I named 3c2 by named it NCR
just because I picked it very well but I
didn't have to name that one NCR suppose
I called this one
it's here if this one is NCR what's the
term before it's NC minus one okay so
what's that equal to well it's still on
the next road right I have to go over
and down which term alone is it it's the
third one which in this scheme here I
have identified as ah do great
so here are two ways survive it which
one is right and some they both right do
you see one like I just started from a
different point of view I can start from
another one same thing I named this one
in C ah then I named this one in C ah
what is it logical the next choices that
I could use how about this one what if I
called this one NCR use do you think
this is equal to this sum of the two
terms on the wrong bar do you agree so
how will I name them how do I say the
rubber bump n minus one that's the wrong
one what's this going to be the tie -
one is look this R so that's clearly on
minus 1 and the last time along I'm on
that row above and minus 1 and then I'm
back to this segment of you do you agree
three ways to write it which do you
prefer
which do you like best
I like the law so except for an IRA okay
um look I I think any of them is fine if
I had to choose one out of them I think
I'd probably choose this one can anyone
tell me why this might be a candidate
yeah
is that negatives and because I'm such a
discriminatory person I don't like
negative also this is modeled on how you
create pascal's training isn't it
you go from one road to the next you go
down the triangle by adding as opposed
to I'll where I might now look backwards
to find out what you came good point so
when you have a look at something like
say this guy and quit and see calling
that NCR you so what run into a problem
because if I were to take that as an
example right I would say what is that
term that's going to be 3 C 3 is it
okay so what's that going to be equal to
how do i how do I interpret from this
so we're at a bit of dilemma
why did we add a dilemma because 2c3
there isn't a ton over there it is there
right so you can see here yes some
definitions are going to be useful in
some contexts some of them break down
because NCR is not defined for any
values in any lack or any values of
argue like for instance this is all are
dissolving whole numbers isn't it
so we haven't talked about anything
about like what if it's one and a half
or nothing to do with that
what if n is negative I still don't have
something to do that either right so
therefore none of these definitions is
what it's fine but each of them says
something sure about the relationship
between these numbers in fact that's why
this last one gets a special name
because it comes out of Pascal's
triangle we call it Pascal's
identity because you know they're very
original with their names
all right so you know what the ends are
you know what the symmetry is you don't
let the sum of every Romans and you know
how these coefficients relate between
work